Steve Mariucci my compadre from NFL
gameday morning here on the Monday's
with mooch post wildcard segment how are
you mooch I'm doing good it's raining
like crazy up here how about down there
in LA it's spitting a little bit down
here right now
maybe this spit don't we we could these
fires and everything I know I know and
it's gonna sound pretty good or it could
be the tears of cheery Chiefs nation
what what is it again Mac naggy the
offensive coordinator of Auntie Reed
just named moments ago reportedly to the
next coach of the Chicago Bears don't
know if you heard that Steve yeah I just
saw that okay talk to me so the question
is what is what is Andy Reed thinking
this morning your buddy well he's he's
thinking that they're gonna be a
different team again next year I mean
you always do next year's team is always
much different you know there's 30 or 40
percent changeover in personnel player
personnel and and often times if you're
successful you'll lose coaches gosh he's
been losing coaches yeah Doug Peterson
is with the Eagles and he's got quite a
coaching tree this was a quick hire I
this this I don't know Matt Nagy
personally and I take pride in knowing
most of the coaches but I don't know
this guy but evidently they want the
Andy Reid way of life over there the way
he practices the way his offensive
scheme the whole thing and develop this
young quarterback Jabbar ski and so on
we go well I mean that that's for the
Bears but I mean what do you think he
you're Andy Reid's walked me through you
know how he views something like this
where where they had it they should have
won it I know they lost their tight end
who got hurt but how does Kareem hunt
wind up with just 11 carries yes he just
didn't have any plays in the second half
you know the Titans had 16 first downs
and the Chiefs had three they couldn't
they couldn't put drives together and
they and they just it was just an awful
second half for them and and that nobody
got the ball and and so you know when
you miss a field goal and you missed you
mentioned Travis Kelsey and Chris Jones
a defensive lineman gets out and all of
a sudden you're just not the same and it
snowballs away from you I mean it's it's
shell-shocked I'm sure it's had it
the better team but they don't advance
its it's a shame Steve Mariucci joining
me here on the Rich Eisen show what what
were the Falcons able to do that few
teams were able to do against the Rams
this year
you know the Falcons are a very good
team and we saw that last year and we
knew how good they were on offense with
the with tomorrow and all the weapons
they have and they were up and down this
year like most teams are and and they
moved the ball against those rams
remember we talked about Ben garland
that the guard replacing Andy levitra
the utility man who plays offense and
defense
he played pretty well against Aaron
Donald and Julio Jones made some plays
and and they slipped around on that turf
down there and made enough plays but the
pelicans defense is better you know it
needed to be better they found that out
last year they were so young they were
playing with about five guys starting
that were first or second-year players
and they're growing up and they got
Trufant back and so that that that
Falcons team is better than it was a
year ago it's more mature and it's more
ready to do this and they were more
experienced there they were they were a
little bit better apt to win a playoff
game than the RAM so the Rams are going
to be super and I can't wait to watch
them next year in their second year
together but the Falcons are for real
rich they are then it sure looks like
the Saints are as well just when you
thought that the reason why they're
succeeding is because Brees is able to
rely on the two running backs and then
it was Brees or damn near threw for 400
yards to get him through to the next
round yeah which team do you think has a
better shot of winning on divisional
weekend the Saints or the Falcons you
know hang on that's Gayle calling that's
Gayle calling I want to shut her off
Joyce she's gonna be mad I'm honored
that the Rich Eisen show just sent your
wife to always mail Steve it's okay
though this is good stuff because you
know we saw the Saints and the Vikings
play in the first week yep and that was
a different game because Sam Bradford
was the quarterback he threw for 346 you
cook wasn't he running back he's no
longer with them he's on IR
so this is a different Vikings team with
Case Keenum and and McKinnon and Murray
at tailback
but I think the Saints certainly have a
good chance of going in there and
playing that's that that's the thing
about being balanced you know we say the
Saints are balanced and drew they don't
just rely on Drew Brees thrown for 5,000
yards but then they have these two
running backs for 15,000 yards each
scrimmage yards and they got held at 22
and 23 yards rushing well pick your
poison you know because then if you load
up the box and try to stop those guys
you know Drew Brees will slice you up is
what that's what he did and we and we
talked about the only way that the
Carolina Panthers had a chance to win
this thing if camp played one of his
great games he did he was terrific and
they came down to the last series man
did earth get his prediction right his
bold prediction I don't recall you know
forty nine yards passing and it came
down what a game that was it really was
that that one was was really a good one
I mean I've hardly even talked a touched
on Jacksonville and Buffalo because it
really was just a difficult watch it was
but that said that Jacksonville defense
is no freaking joke what do you think
about their opportunity to make it a
twofer in Pittsburgh coming up this
weekend Steve you know I don't I don't
think they're gonna win that game but
you're right they have a terrific
defense did you see Dion's interview
when you ball you get the call sir yeah
Jalen C from Florida State yeah and they
both said Thomas showed up and they both
started arguing over who's gonna go to
Antonio Brown I'm sure they both started
arguing over who gets a Antonio Brown
yeah these guys have an edge to that
yeah yeah and and and and I they're good
but you know you go back and watch that
game with Pittsburgh that the game that
Ben was thinking about retiring after
five interceptions that was his worst
game ever and the Steelers were winning
that game nine to seven in the third
quarter not that that's anything to brag
about but then it was picked back back
back it was you know in a couple of pick
sixes and it was such a freaky game it
was just a different game
and it you know you're I think Antonio
Browns can be very healthy and fresh and
been they have confidence and left Bal
there's so many weapons and in
Pittsburgh's not a heck of a defense to
there's a big good game but I I would
consider the Jags winning this a big
upset I really would because Pittsburgh
in my mind should be the better or
all-round team especially in special
teams in offense so basically you think
we're gonna get the AFC Championship
game we all expected yeah I do
alright donors you know you just never
you never know but I do I think
Pittsburgh will win and I think the
Patriots win yes so then what about the
NFC Championship game is it possible
that the Saints go back home to take on
the other division opponent for a third
time is that entirely possible or do you
like Minnesota to shock them and then I
mean it's a that one's wide open but the
NFC's will more wide open and conference
all year long it is and you know the
Falcons go to play the Eagles and you
know they they didn't play this year but
they played last year and they played
when the Falcons were really at their
best on offense okay you know Matt Ryan
was unstoppable and their offense was
breaking records and the Eagles stopped
them the Eagles played a great defensive
game against the Falcons last year and
Carson Wentz was just a baby he didn't
do much in that game but they won jim
schwartz his defense stopped the run
game they held him only 48 yards rushing
and that doesn't happen very often so
the Eagles defense seems to have a way a
know how to slow down this Falcons
offense it's going to be fun to watch so
that one's anybody's bet but the Eagles
are probably pretty confident that they
can win this so give her to me what are
you five what's your NFC Championship
game predict you want me to make a
prediction
yes it's Monday and I'm not gonna stress
the week on the show Steve all right yes
you do Yeah right now so right now you
let me just tell you this this of all
the football weekends that we have
College Pro even high school well high
school football this is my favorite
weekend of the season not even close
divisional round weekend because it's
the Elite Eight and it's
it's all the one in two seeds that got
devised are playing at home against the
teams that won a hard-fought game last
week and it's just always great football
you're right Steve it is it is awesome
it's terrific and I'm gonna send you
overnight if not over the next five
minutes a pair of tweezers to take the
splinters out of your behind and get off
the fence and the Vikings winning in the
NFC Eagles Wow you go you go chalk one
two you go one two he goes chunk I'm
going one twos all the way through I'm
going one twos I like fresh teams versus
Nick Foles is going to bounce Atlanta no
way okay I'm gonna check your homework
on Sun on Saturday Steve Carson Wentz
didn't do anything against these guys
last year okay so even if Nick Foles
doesn't do anything Carson Wentz do you
know they slowed him down they had a I
don't know they they ran the ball they
played great defense those kinds of
things are at home I'm cold you got a
dome team I don't know how much that's a
factor I always get heard about your
dome er yeah and you know they got to go
buddy in the cold and you know I can
change my mind by tomorrow no splinters
it's okay
and you know one last thing do you know
who plays next Saturday during the
wild-card what are we betting sir don't
rub it in because Michigan State had one
of those Mulligan's stop it so your boy
is O's number one he's rolling right now
number one and they go to Ohio State and
they get beat but you know that's okay
they had 15 in a row it's a little wake
up call now to get back on track okay
well we've got lots to discuss at our
Friday meeting let's put it that way
mooch thanks for calling take care you
got it that's uh Steve Mariucci here on
the Rich Eisen show the Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience